bon ok ça va être une belle journée des
jeunes rassemblés sous le soleil
brillant dans un parc non pas pour en
profiter mais pour passer à l'action
à deux mètres de distance puis on donne
du kit aujourd'hui mais le plus
important c'est notre présence la
brigade de bénévoles de l'organisme
hoodstock distribuer des masques pour
soutenir sa communauté
montréal nord il y avait beaucoup de
manquements déjà dans la communauté
pilar avec la situation s'est encore
plus amplifiée on a choisi quelques
points quelques endroits qu'on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de mouvements beaucoup
d'action parce que les gens ne peuvent
pas nécessairement respecter la
distanciation sociale donc on veut
vraiment à lyss be ces endroits là il
met en mouvement comme en mai aps les
masses comme on enlevait après la crise
en ch et celle des l'arrondissement
défavorisés est devenu le foyer
d'éclosion qui inquiète une tempête
annoncée
c'est atroce de voir le monde deux
visions de clarté de prévisions qui
avaient envie avec maria morts ce
quelque chose que tout le monde savait
dans une communauté qui se sent négligé
alors que nombre de ses membres sont au
front la communauté sm on est beaucoup
dans les secteurs essentiels de service
et c'est ça qui cause la problématique
actuelle
les chauffeurs de taxi des infirmières
ou des préposés aux bénéficiaires comme
all et stéphanie gamin qui a dû arrêter
de travailler pour s'occuper de son fils
en confinement amis tiennent beaucoup
parce que moi je vais bouger aussi parce
qu'il faut faire
j'ai de l'argent pour payer mon
appartement sans mer où je ne peux pas
rester centré travailler et risquer sa
vie risquer de faire partie des
statistiques
mille trois cent soixante dix sept
personnes sont infectées à montréal nord
un bilan lourd à porter pour ses
résidents alors on constate m ce qu'ils
y sont devant nous mais ça fait
tellement longtemps qu'aucun mort et en
heure une mauvaise presse qui risque de
continuer d'augmenter avec le dépistage
accru annoncé d'où l'importance des
gestes de solidarité
issigeac audry charbonneau radio canada
montréal nord